bonjour à tous bienvenue sur l'émission
minutes forme je suis votre coach
nicolas je vous présenter le mouvement
du grimpeur aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui avec nous sophie bien sophie
tu vas bien en forme dans un premier
temps je vais te démontrer le mouvement
est bien que le décomposer pour tuer
effectué correctement sont blessés
ensuite tu vas reproduire et je vais
t'expliquer ensuite des murs qui sont
sur l'esprit
on est parti doit placer les mains
largeur des épaules comme ça l'air
d'accord sur la rentrée les épaules
ainsi qu'il écoute tu vas rentrer série
des abdominaux excepté hanche et eu à
effectuer des mouvements de genou vers
l'avant
l'accord tout en restant stable
et au fur et à mesure de l'exercice je
te demander d'accélérer un peu on fait
remonter le cardio
allez vas-y mon pass
il prend bien puis sur les paumes de
mains fixe de son petit effet ce pan sa
rentrée à céret ton ventre et maintenant
tu vas venir toucher avec tes genoux sur
ma main à chaque fois parfait
excellent ans a serré de plus en plus
forte et abdou je sais que ça commence à
trembler à être difficile
mais sans légèrement les fesses à y
accroche toi sur plus forts les abdos
accélère
4 5 6 7 8 9 ok tu t'arrêtes super pole
sur l'exercice du grimpeur on a
sollicité énormément les grands droit
toute la sangle abdominale on va voir
ensemble maintenant l'étirement qui va
permettre de relâcher 7,2 alors se
firent barreaux pendant la même position
de base alors pour l'exercer que tu veux
faire pour effectuer la friction comment
se place vers la même position sauf que
tu vas me relâcher parce que c'est quand
même le but de notre étirements première
pause et les hanches sur le sol ouvrez
la cage thoracique et reculer les
épaules et là tu vas sentir toute la
sangle abdominale s'étirer
pour maintenir cette position une passe
en dessous
d'accord allez à toi
installe toi
la position de tout à l'heure les mains
largeur des épaules tu descends les
poser au sol et son pivot bien ta cage
thoracique recul tes épaules là tu vas
vraiment sentir la sangle abdominale
s'est il maintient cette position une
vingtaine de secondes
lectures m'ont tout doucement la
position roman et hanches
voter
pour les étirements complémentaires je
vous donne rendez vous sur les prochains
épisodes de mieux en a bientôt g peur
les hommes travaillent et sont les
abdominaux les bras et les épaules
entraînez-vous trois à quatre fois par
semaine de trois à six séries de 20 à 50
répétition attention d'autres creuser et
au mauvais engagement des épaules